και είναι και σε χαμηλά πως ωστά γιακ ίσως υπάρξουμε ξελίξη ση επόμενη ημέρα ίσως
στη μαρία παναγιώτου να την ενβι έφερε να κόμη καυ προεδρια της εες τημαρία την
παναιότου δεν την ενδιαέρει η προεδρία της της δέ ούτε τηναι ενδιαφερεί οποιαφσεις την ιγεσία
της της είμαι μέλως της της εδ εξοφίκιο συμμεδέχω τοστο πολιτικό γραφίο αλλά δε με
διαφέρουν δεν ποτε διεκδίκησ αφέσει τη στην ιγεσίατι εδέκ και δεν προεκετανα το κάνω το
ρ επειδή ξανάρχισε η φύνητε ανασχηματισμόύ το πονό διάστημα ι όλαλον υπουργείοθεδιέφερε τη μαρία πναλί
πότς απτ γιοργίας δεν είναιούτε κάνον παίνω στη διαδικάσια νασκεφτό πρώτα θα πρέπει να σας
πω ότι η η θέση του υπουργού από την ημέρα που την αναλαμβάνεις γνωρίσεις ότι
είναι εφήμερη είσαι δώ για ναδώσεις κάθε μέρα το εκατόντησε τα δον του αυτούσου για
όσον είσαι εδώ για το καλό τούτο του τόπο τούτο μας εδιαφέει για όσον είμαστε
εδώ είμαστε υπολλό για παίναντης στους πολίτες έχουμε έναν πρόγραμμα διακυβέρνησης που φίλουμε να ελοποιήσουμε
και το ηλοποιούμε και ντούτον που μα ενδιαφέρε ανωνικο χριστοδουλήσετα δε μου το υπουργια μου
μπο είασεδιεέ νομίζωνουμε κάθε ευτήνεράτηση θα εδιτοτε πως έγινε η πρόταση για να υπορυγόπισεςδ πήρε
εντηλέφωνο που το ίπραδεν τε μαρτες μετά πομενι τη σύσκεψη πεγανν η πολιτική αρχηκή στο
γραφείο το προεδροτότο είχες επικαινωνία με τον προεδαενίται για την υπουργοποια υπορποπίσ όχι ε με
πήρενο πρότρος καιε ενημέρωση ναμάλιστε τάξεπάμε πίσα στες πυρκαγές ναεσί σαν μαρία παναγια το θεωρίσω
ότι σήμερα η χώρα μας έχει την ασφαλια απου πρέεπει κυρς